E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a Maktub estava escrito era fevereiro de
2010 estava sentado com meu avô um Círio
de 75 anos ele com seu Mais barra na
sala de visitas
conversávamos sobre várias histórias e
naquela noite resolveu me contar sobre
sua chegada ao Líbano na década de 40 e
passou a descrever como o país tinha uma
beleza rara entre as décadas de 60 e 70
durante a sua narrativa me prende em
seus olhos e percebi uma Escuridão e seu
olhar
estávamos em guerra o país que recebeu
ele deu a oportunidade de criar seus
filhos após se refugiar agora da
bombardeado eu perguntei a ele o motivo
de tanta briga seu olhar congelou e
ficou cerca de um minuto olhando para
mim e me respondeu o ser humano não tem
limites fomos feitos pelas mãos de Deus
e seremos destruídos pela incapacidade
de diálogo
e após essa frase se levantou e foi se
deitar sem entender Decidi não perguntar
sobre pois a dor de um refugiado É
inenarrável
digo isso como alguém que é filho de um
pai Libanês
imigrante não exatamente um refugiado
mas um sujeito movido pelo Desejo de
refugiar-se no Brasil de 88 para fugir
da triste realidade de guerra daquele
país
exatos dez anos depois eu desembarcava
na Etiópia onde faria uma conexão para o
Egito sim Egito eu no país dos faraós
com a missão de ser professor voluntário
para crianças refugiadas de guerra vocês
podem imaginar a sensação
e depois de longa trintas horas de
viagem e completamente exausto Cheguei
ao aeroporto de Cairu e após descansar
acorda no dia vinte e dois de Dezembro
meu aniversário de 29 anos
permaneci deitada por cerca de 30
minutos ele propus fazer uma reflexão
quem era eu a Kelly Quem era o Bruno
essa reflexão foi de extrema importância
olhar para dentro de mim e perceber que
eu sou um ser imperfeito mas que busca a
perfeição
você se sentiu assim imperfeito
é uma das minhas reflexões foi sobre
estar ali naquele momento no Egito Será
que eu poderia ajudar realmente essas
pessoas
eu teria capacidade o que me afetou digo
afetou mesmo aquilo que me atravessou
visceralmente
ser professor sempre foi meu objetivo de
vida quando estava na Educação Básica
fui aquela criança que tinha muita
dificuldade de aprendizagem nunca
conseguiu entender Matemática Português
ciências geografia enfim era
extremamente difícil entender o mundo na
realidade não Que hoje seja fácil
e quando chegou o momento de fazer a
escolha profissional não hesitei escolhi
história e acima de tudo ser professor
a observar as crianças que ensino pude
perceber que eles faltava algo
habilidade de gerir suas próprias
emoções
a ensinar como gerir emoções é uma
tarefa complexa ninguém nasce com essa
habilidade
E na escola onde trabalho temos a
disciplina de formação humana e
socioemocional nela trabalhamos o
desenvolvimento dessas habilidades
dois momentos da nossa história do
presente confirma minha visão a respeito
da crise que a humanidade está vivendo e
que posteriormente resultaria na minha
missão com essas crianças e as paradas
primeiro em 2015 a foto do pequeno ailan
o que havia se afogado em uma tentativa
de entrar com a família na Grécia um ano
depois a imagem do menino ombro ali
sentado na ambulância sujo de terra e
sangue com seu olhar perdido
crianças têm a chance de construir e
viver suas infâncias
essas cenas também fizeram finalmente
entender o que meu avô havia me dito
enquanto refletia sobre meu papel como
professor que figuras ou para os meus
alunos Quem são eles para mim e meio
essas reflexões pensei nas crianças
refugiadas Será que elas entendiam o que
estava acontecendo
ou simplesmente viram aquelas
atrocidades e se tornavam apenas uma
figura em meio a tudo aquilo
e o projeto de voluntariado pelo qual me
inscrevi era o Tite inforedes um
trabalho que envolvia o ato de lecionar
para crianças refugiadas de guerra
chegando à escola onde atuaria como
professor voluntário fui conhecendo os
professores e acabei descobrindo que
assim com as crianças eles eram
refugiados de Guerra 2 o Sudão um da
Etiópia e um da filha as histórias
contadas por esses professores eram de
grande aprendizado Gostaria de
compartilhar uma delas com vocês do
refugiado no escrito há sete meses Kate
com apenas 27 anos viu seus pais irmãos
irmãs serem assassinadas em sua casa por
um grupo que defendia a permanência do
presidente ditador
segundo ele um dos líderes do bando que
invadiu sua casa Ele disse você ficará
Vivo para contar essa história que
estamos no controle do país e construir
um futuro melhor olhando para mim disse
que país melhor o país os meus pais
destruída por pessoas que nem se
importam com o povo estou aqui refugiado
longe de casa
e sempre que eu ouvi essas histórias
refletir a minha vida minhas escolhas e
principalmente
olhava as crianças imaginava como
reconstruir uma infância que sequer
havia começando fazendo um paralelo com
as crianças refugiadas a observá-las
pude perceber que lhes faltava
habilidade emocional do laço afetivo
essas crianças passaram por muitos
relacionamentos rompidos
perderão os pais e durante a fuga
tiveram contato com pessoas que
posteriormente se perderam e ao conhecer
algumas famílias fiz várias perguntas em
relação ao processo de fuga de seus
países no início às famílias ficaram
desconfiados de que o conteúdo das
conversas fosse encaminhado para o setor
de imigração do governo só depois que a
confiança é criada é que as crianças
traumatizadas
conseguem falar o que viveram em
primeiro lugar é importante para elas
ter com quem conversar em quem confiar é
cenário resultou em feridas emocionais
dos refugiados
principalmente nas crianças
reconstruíram uma infância que sequer
começou é extremamente difícil o
desespero dos Pais é grande todos têm o
desejo de dar a seus filhos o futuro
seguro onde possam construir memórias
afetivas
e esse cenário resulta em crianças com
problemas específicos que necessito de
um trabalho ardo de olhar de uma olhada
emocional segundo a ONU A cada 10
minutos uma criança nasce a partida sem
nacionalidade
adolescentes e jovens que crescem
marginalizadas sem usufruir da Cidadania
você tem ciados a vulnerabilidade da
exploração Na minha percepção parecia
com aquelas crianças necessitavam de
afeto um olhar diferenciado
o diariamente vivo com crianças que são
acostumados a receber em acerto suas
famílias
sejam eles de todos os tipos no entanto
uma criança refugiada não possui tal
relação afetiva Você já experimentou um
abraço de uma criança
em março e se eu dissesse que aquelas
crianças não sabiam que eram calor
humano um abraço
fazer com que ela se perceber sem
entender que eram crianças e tinha o
direito de brincar pular sorrir estudado
e de ter um lar esse deveria ser o
futuro do presente destas crianças com o
professor voluntário percebi que essas
crianças refugiadas tinham criado um
vínculo uma experiência que nunca mais
seria esquecida a descer em crianças de
as porradas fruto dos do deslocamento as
crianças Imigrantes tem sua mente posta
em movimento
sentimentos ideias comportamentos que
tenham curso modificado de forma tão
abrupta quanto uma bala Inesperada de um
terremoto
a refletir nesse cenário fiz uma
contraposição
será que as crianças as quais eu ensino
teriam sensibilidade e perceber essas
crianças são duas realidades totalmente
díspares de um lado temos crianças são
expostas realidade de guerra do outro
crianças que tem seus desafios de áries
que não envolvem nenhum tipo de situação
limite ser professor voluntário me fez
reavaliar meu relacionamento com as
crianças pois não importa nacionalidade
religião situação econômica e etnia
todas são crianças e Todas têm direito
de viver suas infâncias na pluralidade e
na potencialidade dessa palavra Maktub
estava escrito essas crianças estava em
meu destino e isso tinha que acontecer
para que eu pudesse reconhecer o meu
olhar nelas e pela força para acreditar
que o amanhã e é melhor obrigado a
[Aplausos]
E aí
[Música]